[Music]
it's still even though it's yeah it
doesn't have a
[Applause]
[Music]
Hey
so look at my feet
you should be able to stand up some of
you are you trying to get a little
center
Center drops yes but not to your toes
they
and you put your knees underneath the
spec counter
okay
you know it's you but it's not the young
we talk about it's a yin energy just
like victimhood mentality is a yin
energy
it's not the end of self attachment that
allows there's the moral attachment to
your Jung's bad news no okay
so it's wrong and I made the comment
that you have any chemical ER so these
are as if rituals so the movement that
knock it is doing is idealize because
the movement that Luke is doing is
prescribed
so if hookah does a different energy
than whatever not it is doing should
they stay with the as if prescribed not
yet Pavin it is actually wrong you get
that and then when you get two parts
from that as if prescribed pattern Luke
is not actually learning what is learned
through the yin side of the technique
okay so when we watch your knock it was
up it is very mushy because your can be
so for example when if we're here we
have the drill yesterday of the pressure
and his job was to not shut off the
pressure and to be tastin being moved
through the pressure okay so a way of
cooking records a way of bukit shutting
it off is to absorb it in the elbow you
see so here i we generated pressure and
I feel it and I take it here I shut it
off see so if you would feel that shut
off right then this technique now makes
no sense okay so you do a shutoff and
you would just keep coming in into
something else okay
so she has it on boom and now here I
have a turning pattern
well if you reverse engineering that
means she has a pushing pattern if she
shuts it off leaves it off then 9 now
I'm doing this and that's hot right so
she leaves it on leaves it on leaps it
off okay she left it on she leaves it
off right and then the same thing I
should go do something else
he has it on she needs it all right
actually go do something else
so you have a job okay it goes on the
hip then you went up you see the
beginner who can't will shut it off
because of fear so look how slow we're
going on yep yes yes
[Music]
now you receive and now you have to
figure out what on this and this is all
shoulder
Oh
better and now the wet you do we receive
but you have it all you think
on aggression
it's on on his pressure not isolated
tension pressure pressure in the center
pressure and seven much better pressure
in the center not the shoulder I then
received good
that too is
okay so here's my push okay so if you do
like alia let's have Leo Leo goes young
you're you're all talk five feeding you
a weigh 110 pounds so but nevertheless
Lia goes young okay but if I give my
prescribed as if you can me it should be
a penetration so okay so I do that
that's why you do that do you think okay
so you go now what are you gonna do okay
good do it again cuz I shut it off right
it's off and you can feel it's off so
then the movies right there okay now I
want you to try to do that move while I
keep it
okay so it's it's telling you that
there's something to that as if side of
you can he or she does not do whatever
and by not doing whatever not yet does
not do whatever okay and you would be
doing whatever if you change it to me or
if you're doing the technique in the
face that we cannot doing their
prescribed energy that would be whatever
it's not a harmonization and a
pre-programmed harmonization of you know
we get that okay so when I keep it on I
actually kind of force you to have to do
the techniques so you can have to go
around that energy there you go okay now
you know I'm here and I'm gonna go off
what would you do yes okay so same thing
try to do it when it's on you can't do
it okay so you have to go round in yes
okay now I'm very next here what would
you do
yes very good okay now I'm well I'm
alive
okay so I you now take on here Alberta
Energy and you throw okay again if I'm
dead here what would you do
yeah so I'm not dead here and you try it
okay so I'm alive so I come around
whoo that's the end as I've hit the
earth and their story you understand so
now we trade roles and I practice
releasing watch the difference go ah
okay
I practice releasing which makes sense
since I just practiced not really easy
now it's my turn and I just check keep
them but his check for wait I'm not
waiting for pain
check for wait okay so your candy list
something like this stay with the
technique
now I don't need to know anything this
future other than you know don't let go
you see because I'm just doing what I -
there's no as if ritual - I am doing
what has come natural to me what I
walked in the door with so my fears my
habits that's what I believe but that as
in ritual as the Chaska as if you're not
that person
okay any questions misunderstanding on
that
it's a leave your shoulder in this
vertical plane you get up you're going
backwards and you wouldn't be able to
get up good you keep wanting to go back
you see where you have to get up forward
okay so she gets up forward good and
then she would address right do you
understand
so as she starts to address I do you see
actually hits me hey okay if I do one
more tank on
she misses you see that okay
here she comes and I take off and she
missed I only need one more ten times
[Music]
okay so back in the technique whoa
I'm moving too in that fashion and that
angle deviation but it also puts me on
the wrist okay we do it again because it
moves me further down the spiral which
I'm now using to go further down her arm
so wool okay that's I want you to think
ahead in those two ways I'm learning a
lot of tap and I'm moving down her arm
to her wrist
[Music]
and you did it a victim can be boom boom
here comes the new line moving off the
line and down her arms then you do the
technique
don't use the ten Khan to do this throw
okay down the arm okay let's go